hey guys you know these days people try
the strangest things to try and boost
their immune systems and it's all
because of covet you just hear covet
covert just forget about covet for just
a few seconds i'm just so tired of
hearing of it all the time there are
other things that can go wrong like just
the basic cold and flu
the best thing you can do is still the
same as it's always been is by focusing
on your diet to live a healthy lifestyle
so in this video i'm going to show you
the 10 best foods that you can eat that
will boost your immune system let's not
waste any more time let's get to it
[Music]
mushrooms i love eating mushrooms
especially with garlic and cheese man it
just tastes so good
but apart from just tasting good it will
also boost your immune system button
mushrooms for example are high in
selenium polysaccharides if that's how
you pronounce it and b vitamins all of
which increases your immune system
blueberries now this is more expensive
in some countries but if you can get it
get it they contain flavonoids that have
antioxidant properties which are great
for your immune system
chocolate you didn't expect this one did
you
well if you like chocolate here's your
chance you can eat chocolate but not any
chocolate dark brown chocolate because
it has an antioxidant called theobromine
now i don't have to tell you not to go
overboard here because yeah you will
still get fat if you eat too much
chocolate i'm just being straight with
you guys
oysters man i love oysters it's one of
the super foods of the ocean it contains
selenium iron vitamin c zinc and vitamin
a i told you it's a superfood and it
will boost your immune system spinach
another one of my favorites it's another
superfood but you probably already knew
this because maybe when you were younger
you still watch popeye well for some of
you it might be a little bit before your
age anyway spinach will increase your
immune system by giving you folate
vitamin a vitamin c magnesium and iron
garlic do you remember i said i love to
eat garlic with mushrooms well if you do
it you will definitely boost your immune
system because garlic is a top food when
it comes to protecting you from all
kinds of illnesses and you might already
know this because garlic is a home
remedy in most homes
sweet potatoes they contain a lot of
beta-carotene which is a type of vitamin
a that is why it has that orange kind of
color and it's a great immunity booster
food
green tea it's already famous all over
the world for fighting obesity but it's
not just good for that it's also good
for your immune system green tea
contains flavonoids just like
blueberries and it's also great in
fighting cholesterol and heart disease
watermelon now this is this is actually
an awesome idea to eat together as a
family you know because you can create a
lot of sports to come with it but it's
also good because you can increase the
immune systems of your whole family at
the same time it gives you potassium
glutathione vitamin a vitamin b6 and
vitamin c
ginger it's awesome i love to eat it
with sushi a lot of people like to add
it into their tea as well it has
anti-inflammatory qualities and the
antioxidants help to boost your immune
system
the bonus tip the bonus tip is always
for you guys who don't leave my video in
the middle we watch it all the way to
the end and this is the bonus tip of
this week here are a lot more foods that
will boost your immune system broccoli
kefir
almonds
oranges
kiwis
red bell peppers
turmeric
oily fish
elderberries
ouijar
yogurt
miso soup
and pomegranates now if you want more
health videos then check out these ones
here and remember to subscribe and
before you go always remember
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys